Speaker 1: I want to look at a very disturbing
video.
Not disturbing in the sense that it's gory,
not disturbing in the sense that there is
bad words swears.
As we might say, it's disturbing because it
is another one of these examples of how conspiracy
theories rarely live alone in someone's brain.
And we talked about this with Dr. Steven Novella
earlier in the week, and we've talked about
this with other experts on conspiratorial
thinking say, well, flat earth, it's so benign,
OK, you think the Earth is flat?
But that's it doesn't mean, well, no.
Typically, these conspiracy conspiratorial
beliefs come in groups, and an attendee at
a Chuck Grassley town hall said Putin's not
bad because he's fighting Nazis.
And what about the Ukrainian biolabs and the
pedophilia?
And there's deep state corruption in Ukraine,
and it's emblematic of how it's never just
one conspiracy theory and maybe just as disturbing.
Is that Chuck Grassley doesn't seem to push
back against any of these?
Take a look at this.
This is what America has become.
Half of America
Speaker 2: and what you know about Biolabs
find the financing that Putin has stopped
over in Ukraine.
The neo-Nazis, the Nazis and the pedophilia
that goes on in Ukraine,
Speaker 1: by the way, pedophilia.
I just love that.
Not only are they often confused by the conspiracies,
it's a word salad, a pedophilia epidemic.
Come on, guys, OK?
Speaker 2: And boobs that are stopping it
on our news doesn't bring that up.
You know anything about that?
Unidentified: Well, you mentioned four things.
I'm a pedophile
Speaker 2: that's I don't wear their TV special
about Ukraine and pedophile I.
But I do know that human
Unidentified: trafficking and not just sex
trafficking, but human trafficking for economic
slavery
Speaker 2: is an interactive.
It's banned in the United States, but it works
internationally.
And so I suppose that there's some of that
in Ukraine, but I can't say that it's worse
there in other places.
And then what did you bring up the biolabs,
the financing that he stopped over there and
then the Nazi neo-Nazis in Ukraine?
Well, the financing hasn't stopped because
Congress appropriated $14 billion seven for
humanitarian aid for the military.
So so you maybe you just saw on television,
there's no one to watch.
Speaker 1: OK.
No.
He's getting his news exclusively from Facebook.
He doesn't watch TV.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: But you also said that the funding
of the Bible or not by the Bible last I mean
the deep state funding.
Speaker 1: Oh, it's now deep state.
I see.
Speaker 2: Very going back to Biden when he
was vice president, that was the norm, maybe
more than nothing we've been I've been briefed
on the lab, something that was set up in the.
Speaker 1: So, you know, Chuck Grassley is
kind of taking this piece by piece.
But really, the problem here is, sir, you've
fallen for a package of of claims individually,
each of which is not what you've been told.
Is there?
Is there trafficking in Ukraine?
Yes, there a there's a problem with trafficking
in Eastern Europe, but the problem is in Russia
as well.
And Putin's invasion of Ukraine is no more
justified because Ukraine also has trafficking
the biolabs thing.
The biolabs in Ukraine are not unique.
They're not particularly pernicious.
There's nothing special about them.
The U.S. is part of a consortium that funds
research all over the world.
There's many labs in Europe.
Some of them are in Ukraine.
Deep state.
Well, what are you talking about?
It's almost like there is a it's like a starter
pack of conspiracy beliefs where it's like
a word salad.
It just comes out of them almost like they've
taken some kind of conspiratorial, conspiratorial
ayahuasca and everything is just being calm.
It's just, you can't stop it.
They're just vomiting it out into a bucket.
The way many on ayahuasca do, this is an example
of it's never just one conspiracy theory,
and this is what we've been talking about
for a long time.
I would have loved to have seen from Chuck
Grassley.
Remember this moment when, during the 2008
presidential campaign, a woman said to John
McCain, the late Senator John McCain, who
was the presidential candidate.
Obama is a Muslim and he's an Arab.
And McCain said, No, he's not now.
I would have loved to have seen in this clip.
It's also OK to be Muslim in this country.
But OK.
Chuck Grassley not exactly living up to this
standard.
Speaker 3: I can't trust Obama.
I have read about him and he's not.
He's not.
He's a he's an Arab.
He is not.
No, no.
Speaker 2: No, ma'am.
No, ma'am.
He's a he's a he's a decent family man citizen
that I just happen to have disagreements with
on fundamental issues, right?
Speaker 1: And also, if he was an an Arab
or Muslim, as people would say at the time,
sometimes you're allowed to be Muslim and
president in the United States.
I mean, we haven't had one.
OK, but you're you're you actually are allowed
to do it.
So Chuck Grassley not not even living up to
that standard, but this stuff is dangerous,
and the Republican Party by and large at least
welcomes it by looking the other way.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
The David Pakman
Show continues to depend on
you to fund what we do.
We have a membership program at join Packman
dot com and I would love for you to sign up.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
And you can use the code woud 22 to save a
surprising amount off of the cost of a membership.